[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Siebers guten
Abend in allen haben Sie schon mal
gehört von PET geldsinger vermutlich
nicht der Mann ist Chef des
Chip-Herstellers Intel und wird gerade
in Deutschland hofiert nicht nur der
Bundeskanzler empfängt ihn heute sondern
auch eine Menge Geld die Bundesregierung
liegt eine gigantische Förderung auf den
Tisch wenn Intel ein neues Werk in
Magdeburg baut dort investiert und
Arbeitsplätze schafft das ist in gleich
mehrerer Hinsicht bemerkenswert
angefangen mit der Scheren Summe 9,9
Milliarden für ein einziges Unternehmen
auch weil Europa unabhängiger werden
will in der Halbleiterproduktion
Pat Gelsinger so muss man das sehen hat
eine ausgezeichnete Verhandlungsposition
aber genau da beginnen auch die Fragen
Andreas Weise
ein gut gelaunter Amerikaner vor dem
Kanzleramt in Berlin Intel-Chef
petgelsinger hat es geschafft noch mal
gut 3 Milliarden Euro für sein
Megaprojekt in Magdeburg herauszuholen
die Vereinbarung mit der Regierung
umfasst 9,9 Milliarden an Beihilfen die
sie zur Verfügung stellen ich sage das
immer wieder das sind riesen Summen
außerordentliche Investitionen aber für
jeden Dollar der von der Regierung kommt
packen wir mehr als zwei dazu es ist ein
gewaltiges Engagement unsererseits in
den deutschen in den europäischen Markt
Ukraine Krieg Inflation neue
Technologien all das macht das Projekt
Magdeburg deutlich teurer zu Intel 30
Milliarden Euro will man in den
bördeboden stecken die größte
ausländische Einzelinvestitionen die es
je in Deutschland gab vor der Einigung
heute gab es wochenlang Debatten wo denn
die zusätzlichen subventions Milliarden
herkommen sollen Finanzminister Lindner
wollte sein Portemonnaie nicht noch mal
öffnen Wirtschaft sind klimaminister
habe ich springt nun ein wir wissen dass
Digitalisierung die auf der einen Seite
neben Investitionen auch hohe
Energieverbräuche mit sich bringt und
jeder technologische Weiterentwicklung
einsparen hilft ist ein Benefit für die
Klimaentwicklung und für den Klimaschutz
und deswegen ist auch die Differenz zur
großen Teilen aus dem klimafond gekommen
und da bin ich schon habe ich dankbar
dass er sozusagen diesen inneren
Zirkelschluss mit uns gemeinsam
entwickelt hat Lob für Robert Habeck von
einem CDU-Politiker das gibt es auch
nicht alle Tage doch über die
Parteigrenzen hinweg war es unbedingt
gewollt dass dieses Projekt gelingt
Europa soll bei Schlüsseltechnologien
autarker werden die Mittel die jetzt
bereitgestellt werden sind Ausgleich zu
den etwas höheren Kosten die wir in
Deutschland haben verglichen mit Asien
ich möchte jedenfalls nicht so eine
Abhängigkeit von Russland hatten von
China oder Taiwanern haben fragt sich
nur ob knapp 10 Milliarden Euro
Subventionen für anfangs gut 3.000
Arbeitsplätze nicht etwas viel sind auch
wenn Intel in Zukunft deutlich mehr Jobs
plant und auch viele Zulieferer noch
kommen
es hat ausstrahl Effekt auf die ganzen
neuen Länder wir sehen ja was Tesla
auslöst in Brandenburg insofern ordnet
es sich auch ein in den politikstrategie
in europäischen Strategie in dem Bereich
der Produktion Halbleiter mehr in
Deutschland zu haben aber
subventionstöpfe sind nicht nach oben
offen und man kann nicht beliebig
nachverhandeln und ich finde es auch
schwierig wenn Unternehmen den Eindruck
erwecken dass sie einen
subventionswettbewerb in Gang setzen und
die Drohung Produktion nach Übersee zu
verlagern sieht meist immer wir haben
nur die Möglichkeit zu entscheiden ob
wir dieses globale Spiel mitspielen dann
wird es teuer ja aber noch mal wir haben
dann eine solche Standort mitten in
Europa oder wir scheiden aus aus dem
Wettrennen das kann auch nicht das Ziel
der Veranstaltung sein denn vor allem
die USA locken ihrerseits mit mega
Subventionen für Zukunftstechnologien
die intern Milliarden müssen jetzt noch
von der EU-Kommission in Brüssel
abgesegnet werden dann soll es Ende
diesen oder Anfang nächsten Jahres
losgehen am südwestlichen Stadtrand von
Magdeburg
ein Grundstück in Magdeburg hat bereits
erworben dort graben Archäologen derzeit
nach Überresten aus der Jungsteinzeit
wenn man das Werben um die Firma heute
als Maßstab nimmt dann dürften solche
Funde kein Hindernis sein für eine
künftige Fabrik Justus Hauke ist
Wirtschaftswissenschaftler an der Uni
Düsseldorf und jetzt bei uns für so
einen kleinen Einblick hinter die
Kulissen Herr Professor guten Abend
guten Abend Herr Sievers 10 Milliarden
Subventionen für ein einzelnes
Unternehmen wird Ihnen da schwindelig
ja da wird mir schwindelig das ist schon
eine wahnsinnig hohe Summe sie haben es
eben gesagt 3000 Arbeitsplätze zehn
Milliarden Euro das sind also 3
Millionen ungefähr pro Arbeitsplatz und
selbst wenn man sieht dass da noch viele
Arbeitsplätze drumherum entstehen ist
das doch sehr sehr viel Geld um man
fragt sich ob diese Wertschöpfung jemals
wieder reingeholt werden kann vielleicht
machen wir mal so ein Vergleich auf es
gibt ja diesen digitalpakt Schule mit
der die deutschen Schulen mit dem die
deutschen Schulen fit für die digitale
Zukunft gemacht werden sollen da sind 5
Milliarden also gerade mal die Hälfte
vorgesehen hätten sie eine andere Idee
was man mit diesen 10 Milliarden machen
könnte und was möglicherweise dann viel
besser wirkt auch gesamt in der
deutschen Wirtschaft
ja also wir haben tatsächlich ein paar
Standorte Nachteile von daher ist es ja
gar nicht schlecht dass man sagt wir
müssen ein bisschen was tun um die
Wirtschaft in bestimmten Bereichen in
Schwung zu bringen aber tatsächlich bei
der Digitalisierung haben wir Nachteile
und Nachholbedarf und der wird natürlich
nicht dadurch gelöst dass jetzt Chips in
Deutschland produziert werden die dann
überall in die ganze Welt letztendlich
exportiert werden sondern dass wir was
tun für die digitale Infrastruktur aber
auch für die Forschung und Entwicklung
und wenn man ich sag mal in
Sachsen-Anhalt oder auch in anderen
Bundesländern das Geld in Forschung und
Entwicklung sowohl an Universitäten aber
auch bei privaten mittelständischen
Unternehmen gegeben hätte da wäre ich
sehr viel optisch optimistischer als das
da sehr sehr viele Patente rausgekommen
werden mit dem man viel hätte machen
können jetzt gibt's ja der noch ein
zusatzargument der Befürworter dieser
riesensubvention die sagen es geht eben
nicht um irgendein Produkt sondern ein
lebenswichtiges wenn man so will nämlich
um Chips braucht es eine solche
staatliche Förderung um die Technologie
und Produktion tatsächlich stärker nach
Europa zu holen quasi als Versicherung
gegen Lieferausfälle in der Zukunft
die Idee dass man sich unabhängiger von
Asien machen will die ist ja im Prinzip
gar nicht schlecht die Frage ist nur ob
das jetzt wirklich gelingt mit dem was
jetzt geplant ist denn wir dürfen auch
nicht vergessen die chips-magdeburg die
werden jetzt nicht aus Kartoffeln
produziert sondern auch Seltenen Erden
mit seltenen Metallen da gibt es nach
wie vor eine große Abhängigkeit von
China und Asien und von daher werden wir
die nicht ganz lösen man sollte
sicherlich diversifizieren und wir sehen
Intel baut parallel auch Werke in Polen
in Israel in Irland wird schon
produziert von daher werden
Diversifizierung eigentlich dass dieser
Gebote der Stunde nicht unbedingt alles
unbedingt in Deutschland machen wo es
vielleicht auch noch am teuersten ist
und wir letztendlich auch anderen
Betrieben in der Nachbarschaft oder auch
in der Leitung ungefähr Entfernung dann
die Fachkräfte auch noch abjagen mit
Hilfe von staatlichen Subventionen sie
haben andere Betriebe angesprochen ist
es auch so eine Art Präzedenzfall den
wir da jetzt schaffen dass also das
nächste Unternehmen sagt das klingt ja
ganz gut und das was Intel bekommen hat
das will ich auch
natürlich dass das führt immer zu
Begehrlichkeiten das andere sagen wenn
Intel so viel mehr Geld bekommt dann
hätte ich auch gerne noch mal ein
Schnaps oben drauf und letztendlich
stellt sie auch die Frage ob wir nicht
dadurch eine neue Abhängigkeit schaffen
was ist denn wenn Intel in 6 7 8 Jahren
sagt die Standortbedingungen sind zu
schlechte brauchen wieder Geld damit wir
hier bleiben ich erinnere mich noch als
vor 15 Jahren Nokia den Standort Bochum
verlassen hat nachdem sie zehn Jahre
lang Subventionen kassiert haben und
dann doch abgewandert sind also eine
Garantie dass das auf ewig bleibt die
haben wir jetzt nicht
verstehe Professor das die Gefahr
besteht dass wir tatsächlich erpressbar
werden oder bereits jetzt auch schon
erpresst werden als Steuerzahler
naja also das die großen
multi-nationalen Unternehmen im
Wettrennen um die Subventionen natürlich
auch versuchen die Standorte
gegeneinander auszuspielen und
letztendlich dorthin gehen wo sie dann
doch die meisten Subventionen und die
besten Bedingungen bekommen das ist
sicherlich Aussicht dass sie aus und der
Anteilseigner der Unternehmen
nachvollziehbar aber nicht unbedingt gut
für den deutschen Steuerzahler jetzt
heißt es umgekehrt natürlich auch immer
wieder Abwanderung die
Industrialisierung dieses Gespenst geht
ja seit einiger Zeit um in Deutschland
alle warnen davor jetzt sehen wir heute
mal den gegenteiligen Schritt nämlich
eine große Ansiedlung von neuer
Industrie und das ist auch wieder
schlecht
naja das ist eigentlich natürlich schon
ganz gut dass wir auch wieder Industrie
ansiedeln aber wir sehen auch es geht
anscheinend nicht dass sie von alleine
kommen sondern wir müssen einen großen
Topf aufmachen um sie überhaupt
anzulocken weil wir tatsächlich hohe
Energiekosten haben hohe Steuerkosten
Steuern bei den Unternehmen in
Fachkräftemangel das macht das auch
nicht attraktiver wir haben auch wenn
man ganz offen und ehrlich ist doch
Defizite in der öffentlichen
Infrastruktur sowohl in der klassischen
Infrastruktur aber auch in der
Leistungsfähigkeit der öffentlichen
Verwaltung also von daher wir müssen
schon dran an die Standortbedingungen
aber wenn man sagt wir versuchen das
Problem zu lösen indem wir möglichst
viel Geld drauf werfen dann löst man das
jetzt einmal für ein Unternehmen aber
natürlich nicht strukturell diese
Probleme
interessanterweise wenn man noch mal auf
dieses Unternehmen jetzt ganz konkret
schauen geht es Intel derzeit ja nicht
besonders rosig der Umsatz gegen
deutlich zurück hat gerade den bislang
größten Quartalsverlust gemeldet wie
sicher ist denn so eine Investition
überhaupt in Intel in dieses Unternehmen
aktuell
gut da wäre ich vielleicht nicht ganz so
pessimistisch selbst wenn Intel obwohl
der Börsenkurs ja auch heute zugelegt
hat zumindest in Europa also anscheinend
das noch mal rotiert wurde diese diese
Vereinbarung die geschlossen worden ist
selbst wenn Intel jetzt dann doch
letztendlich nicht mehr existieren würde
würde ich hätte ich ein Gewissen
Optimismus hat zumindest die
Produktionskapazitäten dann schon von
jemand anders übernommen werden würden
denn das ist ja schließlich ein Wert und
das haben wir in der Vergangenheit auch
in Dresden durchaus gesehen dass
Produktionskapazitäten wenn die eine
Firma ausgeschrieben ist dann doch von
anderen übernommen werden ist von daher
da wäre ich vielleicht nicht ganz so
pessimistisch wie andere
Professor vielen Dank für diese Analyse
heute Abend live hier im heute schon mal
sehr sehr gerne vielen Dank fürs
Gespräch danke ja unabhängig werden für
den Krisenfall haben wir ja gerade
besprochen das heißt vor allem
unabhängig von China aktuell sind wir
alles andere als das wir wissen wir
brauchen China auch wenn wir China gerne
weniger stark brauchen würden das ist
der Drahtseilakt den die Berliner
Politik gerade versucht der
Bundespräsident empfängt heute den
Ministerpräsidenten aus China auf dessen
erster Auslandsreise ab morgen sitzen
dann die chinesische und die deutsche
Regierung zu Gesprächen zusammen zwei
Wettbewerber die auch Partner sind und
Rivalen und dann noch nach einer
passenden Formel suchen
heute bereits eine wichtige Zäsur im
Verhältnis China USA Anthony blinken ist
in Peking und dort hatte der
amerikanische Außenminister auch ein
Treffen mit dem chinesischen
Staatspräsidenten das ist ungewöhnlich
und zumal an einem Tiefpunkt der
gemeinsamen Beziehungen ein echtes
Symbol Elisabeth Schmidt
in großen Städten wie Peking sind sich
China und die USA schon seit vielen
Jahren nah überall große amerikanische
Fastfood-Ketten Cafés und Lifestyle
Produkte iPhone Tesla und andere
US-Exporte sie gelten keineswegs als
unerwünscht sondern als Statussymbole
doch politisch hat die Staatsführung die
USA jahrelang zum großen Feind erklärt
Propaganda die verfängt
getan die USA sagen dass eine und tun
das andere
ich wünschte die USA würden aufhören
Taiwan ständig zu unterstützen es wäre
schön wenn die beiden Großmächte
miteinander Auskämmen
miteinander auskommen es sind die
subtilen Botschaften mit denen blinken
von staatschefski heute empfangen wird
ein langer Tisch hier am Kopfende ein
Zeichen von macht doch zwischen ihm und
der amerikanischen Delegation
Lotusblüten die Staatsmedien verbreiten
die Botschaft die Blumen sein ein Symbol
für Zusammenarbeit und Frieden
wir haben Fortschritte in den
Beziehungen erzählt und auch über
Einkünfte in einigen Punkten das ist
sehr gut ich hoffe dass sie durch ihren
Besuch Herr Außenminister positiv zur
Stabilisierung unserer Beziehungen
beitragen werden
das Treffen Blinkens mit Chinas
top-diplomaten Wang i am Vormittag noch
deutlich unterkühlter Wang sprach davon
dass die Beziehungen auf einem Tiefpunkt
sein die schuldschuppe allein den USA zu
woran man übereinstimmte man brauche
sich vor allem auch wirtschaftlich es
ist die Verantwortung beider Länder dass
wir einen Weg aus der Krise finden dass
es in unserem Interesse und im Interesse
der Welt
blinken sei es allerdings nicht gelungen
China dazu zu bewegen die direkten
militärischen Kommunikationskanäle
wieder aufzumachen ein großes Anliegen
der USA um eine weitere Eskalation des
Taiwan Konflikts zu verhindern und doch
gibt es kleine Fortschritte
der Erfolg des Treffens ist dass beide
Seiten wieder einen normalen Kontakt
hergestellt haben die Beziehungen sind
nicht weiter auseinander gedriftet ich
denke es wird weitere bilaterale Treffen
geben in den nächsten Monaten im
November dann auch zwischen hi und
US-Präsident beiden in San Francisco auf
dem Wirtschaftsgipfel der Asiatisch
pazifischen Länder
Chinas Außenminister werde auf Einladung
Blinkens bald zu einem Gegenbesuch nach
Washington reisen hieß es in Peking noch
China und die USA sie sind sich heute
auch politisch wieder näher gekommen
ja mal sehen wie das dann morgen läuft
mit China und Deutschland weitere
wichtige Nachrichten jetzt von heute
erstmal im Überblick und den hast du
Hanna ja
klar sollen künftig
und einwandern können unter welchen
Bedingungen darauf hat sich nun
abschließend die Ampelkoalition geeinigt
unter anderem soll es einen Punktesystem
nach kanadischem Vorbild geben außerdem
ist geplant dass der Arbeitsmarkt auch
für qualifizierte Asylbewerber geöffnet
wird deren Verfahren bereits in
Deutschland läuft noch diese Woche soll
der Bundestag über den Gesetzentwurf
abstimmen
gegen den Inhaftierten russischen
Oppositionsführer alexena valny hat ein
neuer Prozess wegen extremismusvorwürfen
begonnen das Verfahren findet in einem
Straflager unter Ausschluss der
Öffentlichkeit statt er war nie wird
unter anderem vorgeworfen eine
extremistische Organisation gegründet
und finanziert zu haben der
kremmelkritiker weiß dies zurück bei
einer Verurteilung drohen ihm bis zu 30
weitere Jahre Haft
eine razziale des israelischen Militärs
investorde an Land sind mindestens fünf
Palästinenser getötet und Dutzende
Menschen teils schwer verletzt worden
das erklärte das palästinensische
Gesundheitsministerium dem israelischen
Militär zufolge kam es zu einem
mehrstündigen Schusswechsel mit
militanten Palästinensern dabei sei ein
Kampfhubschrauber eingesetzt worden um
den Rückzug der Soldaten zu ermöglichen
die EU und Kenia haben sich auf ein
Freihandelsabkommen geeinigt dadurch
kann das ostafrikanische Land künftig
zollfrei Produkte in die Europäische
Union exportieren im Gegenzug will Kenia
seinen Markt schrittweise für
europäische waren öffnen die EU ist der
wichtigste Exportmarkt Kenias das Land
führt vor allem landwirtschaftliche
Produkte wie Kaffee und Blumen aus
und wir bleiben noch im Moment beim
Blick nach Afrika es ist ein bangerblick
den die bundesinnenministerin da heute
tut in Tunesien wo sie versuchen will
das Land zu gewinnen als Partner der
verhindert das künftig weiterhin so
viele Menschen von dort übers Mittelmeer
nach Europa kommen Tunesien ist ein
Haupt-
für die vermeintlichen Verlockungen
Europas riskieren sie ihr Leben Tag und
Nacht bringt Tunesiens Küstenwache
solche Boote auf
Seelenverkäufer voller Menschen auf dem
Weg über das Mittelmeer
sind in dieser Zeit mehr und mehr
geworden im Vergleich zu den vergangenen
Jahren hat die Zahl deutlich zugenommen
24.000 könnten es jetzt schon sein
sechsmal mehr als vor einem Jahr
gemeinsam mit dem französischen
Amtskollegen müht sich die
Innenministerin in Tunis deswegen heute
mögliche Abkommen vorzubereiten bietet
an legale Zuwanderung etwa für
Fachkräfte wesentlich zu erleichtern
wenn Tunesien bei der Abschattung gegen
illegale Migration hilft ausgerechnet
der Gastgeber aber äußert sich danach zu
den Gesprächen nicht was sie zu
erreichen hofften müssen die deutsche
und der Franzose den Medien alleine
erklären das geht darum das furchtbare
sterben im Mittelmeer zu beenden es geht
um
Menschenrechtsstandards es geht darum
auch
legale Wege zu schaffen damit Menschen
in Europa
einwandern können aber nicht sich auf
gefährliche Wege begeben müssen und
dabei spielt eine ganz wesentliche Rolle
auch die gemeinsame Bekämpfung von
Schlepper und unser Kriminalität die in
aller drei Länder Interessen liegt
diese Unterstützung soll vor allem dazu
dienen tunesische Polizei und
grenzschutztruppen zu verstärken um den
illegalen Flüchtlingen Einhalt zu
gebieten und ihre Rückkehr zu
erleichtern Tunesien selbst ist das
erste Opfer der ungeregelten Migration
deshalb möchten wir unsere Solidarität
zum Ausdruck bringen
schon länger umwirbt die EU Tunesiens
autokratischen Präsidenten verspricht
auch Geld bis zu einer Milliarde für
Entgegenkommen bislang mit wenig Erfolg
die Menschen sind
Opfer eines globalen Systems dass sie
wie Nummern behandelt wir können nicht
die Wächter für diese Länder sein
im Falle Tunesiens ist entscheidend ob
eine Koalition von europäischen Staaten
gemeinsam mit der Europäischen
Kommission ein attraktives Angebot macht
das für Tunesien wichtig ist und das
nicht unseren Werten widerspricht
Tunesiens Regierung kann auf Zeit
spielen und tut das auch so steigt der
politische Preis denn mit jedem
Flüchtlingsboot das von hier ablegt wird
der Druck auf Europa größer
die Frage nach der richtigen
Flüchtlingspolitik geht auch wie ein
Riss quer durch die Linkspartei und es
ist nicht der einzige Riss dort bei der
Linken steht die Frage im Raum ob aus
all den inhaltlichen und personellen
Brüchen jetzt die Spaltung folgt aus
einer Linkspartei macht quasi 2 womit
wir bei Sarah Wagenknecht wären die
offen über eine neue Partei nachdenkt
und dabei ihren aktuellen Parteivorstand
so dermaßen verstört dass der ohne sie
mal weitermachen will Heikes lanski
jetzt über das Innenleben einer
zerzausten Partei
es ist ein Abschied auf Raten Sarah
Wagenknecht die prominenteste Linke hat
den innerparteilichen Richtungsstreit
verloren sie steht für klassische linke
Themen gute Löhne gute Rente soziale
Sicherheit die Partei jedoch will das
Spektrum erweitern zwischen machen wir
eine Politik die vor allem in
großstädtischen studentischen Kreisen
überhaupt akademischen Kreisen sehr gut
ankommen mag aber das sind eben oft auch
junge Leute aus sehr gut situierten
Elternhäusern die sich nicht über die
soziale Frage politisiert haben sondern
über Klimafragen Antirassismus Sexismus
also das was heutzutage oft als Links
gilt wofür steht die Linke Klaus Ernst
Gewerkschafter von Anfang an dabei
fremdet mit manch einer Partei Aktion
zum Beispiel der Aufruf der Linken gegen
die Internationale Automobilausstellung
in seiner Heimat so etwas verstößt seine
Anhänger die Arbeiter vor den Kopf diese
Ausstellung dient ja dazu die neuen
Produkte unter anderem auch
Elektrofahrzeuge auch
wasserstofffahrzeuge sondern unter die
Leute zu bringen und von dem lebt zum
Beispiel auch meine Region wir sind ja
Zulieferer für die Automobilindustrie
und wenn sie ja ziemlich die Linke Suppe
ist positioniert wir wollen keine solche
Ausstellung also eigentlich
autofeindlich positioniert dann bedeutet
es dass sie natürlich von den Leuten
auch nicht mehr gewählt werden wird
genossen
gebürtige Polin zu Hause in Hamburg ihr
Landesverband begrüßt den Partei
Beschluss eine Zukunft ohne Wagenknecht
und hat sie gleich mit dem Visier dieser
Beschluss geht auch an unsere
Bundestagsabgeordnete nastic ist auf der
Webseite zu lesen
und das ist aber auch ein Ausdruck
dessen dass man eben einen ganzen Teil
der Partei also ob mich im persona in
Hamburg eine Sahra Wagenknecht auf
Bundesebene oder eben viele in der
Mitgliedschaft und Wählerschaft ganz
klar nicht mehr dabei haben möchte und
die Linke verkommt somit Schritt für
Schritt zu einer kleinen Kleinstpartei
ja in Richtung sektiererschaft die Linke
im Umbruch die Parteizentrale beflagt
für Pride man mehr Toleranz in der
Gesellschaft dafür rückt Altersarmut an
den Rand die Parteispitze gerne bei
Umweltaktionen mittendrin klimakleber
oder lützerat die linke Eifer den Grünen
nach Wagenknecht und Konsorten stören
für uns ist jetzt auch damit einen
Schlussstrich gezogen und wir
konzentrieren uns jetzt drauf wie wir
die Linke wieder erfolgreich machen
stehen Landtagswahlen an in Hessen und
in Bayern dass sie geht steht fest auch
Wagenknecht plant eine Zukunft ohne die
Linke mit einer eigenen Partei es geht
ja heute vor allem darum dass ganz ganz
viele Menschen das sehen wir ja sich von
keiner Partei mehr repräsentiert fühlen
das sind Menschen die wenig Einkommen
haben aber es ist auch die klassische
Mittelschicht das sind Handwerker das
sind kleine selbstständige das sind ja
ganz ganz viele die einfach den Kopf
schütteln über die ampelpolitik was ist
links Wagenknecht bleibt sich treu die
Linke dagegen stellt sich breiter auf
der ursprüngliche Markenkern im Abseits
so wir haben die Sendung begonnen mit
wichtigen Nachrichten aus der deutschen
Industrie und Kender jetzt noch mal hin
zurück mit Diana
in Berlin hat heute nämlich der Tag der
Industrie begonnen mit Rang hohen
Vertretern aus Wirtschaft sowie Politik
und mit klarer Kritik an letzteren der
Unmut der Branche über den Kurs der
Bundesregierung war heute
unüberhörbar Frank Bethmann BDI
Präsident spricht von einem ganzen Berg
von Herausforderungen welche sind das
genau und wie lauten seine Forderungen
schon länger in der deutschen Wirtschaft
die Unternehmenssteuern und die
Lohnkosten gehörten mit zu den höchsten
der Welt zuletzt dann noch die
dramatisch gestiegenen Energiekosten und
so sagen sich inzwischen viele Konzernen
Lenker ist rechnet sich
betriebswirtschaftlich immer weniger in
Deutschland noch zu investieren von der
Regierung forderte der einflussreiche
BDI-Präsident daher heute vor allem
dauerhaft wettbewerbsfähige Strompreise
niedrige Steuern sowie schnelle
Planungs- und Genehmigungsverfahren der
Kanzler aber hält dagegen
Priorität hat dass wir klimaneutral
werden und ein starkes Industrieland
bleiben
deshalb investieren wir in den Ausbau
der erneuerbaren Energien in neue
Technologien in umweltfreundliche
Mobilität und klimafreundliche Gebäude
aber nach einer systematischen
Wirtschafts- oder Strukturreform hört
sich das erst einmal nicht an wie könnte
man denn beides zusammenbringen so dass
die deutsche Wirtschaft künftig sowohl
klimafreundlich als auch konkurrenzfähig
ist schließlich geht es dabei ja auch um
viele Arbeitsplätze ja der BDI sagt die
Energiewende so wie sich das Scholz
vorstelle bringt erstmal kein
zusätzliches Wachstum die
Bundesregierung sieht das anders man
hofft auf ein grünes Wirtschaftswunder
und stellt zumindest kleinere
Steuerentlastungen in Aussicht Stichwort
super Abschreibungsmöglichkeiten
Unternehmen die künftig verstärkt in
Klimaschutz und Digitalisierung
investieren sollen diese dann besonders
hoch und damit Steuern sparend
abschreiben können vielen Dank für diese
Einordnungen
der Flugzeugbauer Airbus hat einen
rekordauftrag erhalten er soll 500
Flugzeuge des Typs A320 an die indische
billig Airline Indigo liefern weil
Unternehmen betonten dass es sich um den
bisher größten Auftrag in der zivilen
Luftfahrt handele dort Listenpreis haben
die Maschinen einen Wert von rund 50
Milliarden Euro allerdings werden bei
Großaufträgen umfangreiche Rabatte
gewährt
zwei Jahre wurde verhandelt jetzt ist
der Einstieg des chinesischen
Staatskonzerns kosko an einem Hamburger
Containerterminal endgültig besiegelt
cosco beteiligt sich mit
24,99 Prozent wegen der Bedenken
mehrerer Ministerien wurde dem Konzern
lediglich eine Minderheitsbeteiligung
gestattet dieser hatten vor einem zu
großen Einfluss Chinas auf europäische
Häfen gewarnt
und es gibt eine aktuelle
Unwetterwarnung des Deutschen
Wetterdienstes und zwar vor schweren
Gewittern mit heftigem Starkregen und
Hagel im Südwesten Bayerns
der britisch-amerikanische
Schriftsteller Salman Rusty erhält den
diesjährigen Friedenspreis des Deutschen
Buchhandels wo steht sei trotz seines
Lebens in ständiger Gefahr einer der
leidenschaftlichsten Verfechter der
Freiheit des Denkens und der Sprache
erklärte der Stiftungsrat
1989 hatte der iranische
Revolutionsführer Comedy einen
tötungsaufruf gegen den Schriftsteller
erlassen vergangenen Sommer war der
76-Jährige bei einem Attentat schwer
verletzt worden wo Stiehl erhält den
Friedenspreis im Herbst in der
Frankfurter Paulskirche
vor der Küste Nordamerikas sucht die
US-Küstenwache derzeit nach einem U-Boot
das für touristische Tugend zum Wrack
des gesunkenen Kreuzfahrtschiffes
Titanic genutzt wird seit gestern früh
ist es verschollen der
us-wache zu Folge waren fünf Menschen an
Bord ob sich darunter auch Touristen
befanden war zunächst unklar der
Betreiber des U-Boots erklärte man
mobilisieren Optionen um die Besatzung
wohlbehalten zurückzubringen Überreste
der Titanic liegen in rund 3.800 Metern
tiefer
ja da kann man nur hoffen auf das Beste
so viel von uns für heute gerne bis
morgen noch einen schönen Abend tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend das wird eine gewitterwoche
und das mit den Gewittern geht schon
jetzt in der zweiten Nachthälfte los die
breiten sich hier über Baden-Württemberg
Rheinland-Pfalz und das Saarland aus
morgen früh ziehen Sie dann weiter
Richtung Nordosten am Vormittag
berücksichtigt die Lage erstmal aber
schon am Nachmittag kommen dann neue
kräftige Schauer und Gewitter von Westen
heran und bis zum Abend erreichen die
etwa eine Linie Schleswig-Holstein
schwäbische alt heute Nacht also gibt's
diese Gewitter im Westen und einige
Regenschauer an der Ostsee sonst wird
das noch eine ruhige Nacht aber eine
sehr warme die Temperaturen sinken auf
20 bis 14 Grad in Schleswig-Holstein bis
Kühler mit elfrath und morgen erwarten
uns schweißtreibende Höchsttemperaturen
zwischen 27 und 34 Grad und nur in den
Küsten von Ost und Nordsee ist es bei 24
oder 25 Grad angenehmer es gibt morgen
noch einige Regionen in denen sie noch
länger die Sonne sehen werden hier
nordöstlich der Elbe und auch in Bayern
sonst gibt's kräftige Gewitter und mit
denen haben wir es dann auch noch am
Mittwoch zu tun bei 24 20 bis 32 Grad am
Donnerstag drohen dann kräftige Unwetter
zum Teil mit heftigem Hagel und am
ehesten von Gewittern verschont bleiben
sie in Norddeutschland die gute
Nachricht zum Schluss ist am Freitag
beruhigt sich die Lage bei
Höchsttemperaturen von 21 bis 26 Grad
und damit wünsche ich Ihnen einen
schönen Abend